RICK HARRISON: So
what exactly is this?
CHRIS: This is an original
Nepalese Bira gun.
RICK HARRISON: I can
honestly say I've never
actually seen one of these.
But it's pretty amazing.
CHRIS: I think there are
probably less than 25 around.
RICK HARRISON: You
can ask my wife
and kids, I always
have something to say,
but I'm a little speechless
at the moment, ah--
CHRIS: I'm a gun collector.
And I work in the
firearms industry.
And this Bira gun
fell into my lap.
And it was an opportunity
that I just couldn't pass up.
I'm asking for $30,000, which
I think is a fair price.
RICK HARRISON: Does it work?
CHRIS: I've been told it works.
So you haven't fired it?
CHRIS: I have not fired this.
RICK HARRISON: Can I open it up?
CHRIS: Sure.
[music playing]
RICK HARRISON: I mean
the machining looks nice.
And how much do you want for it?
I am asking $30,000 $30,000.
RICK HARRISON:
$30,000, well that
is a figure I have no idea on.
Let me call up a friend.
Let me get him down here.
I just want him to
look at this thing,
confirm it's old enough
for me to buy it, OK?
Because if this thing
is post 1899 or newer,
I'm not going to deal in it.
Because then we have to
start doing federal paperwork
and everything like that.
So if everything checks
out with the date,
can you take this out to
the firing range tomorrow?
CHRIS: We can.
I have a vehicle that
will get this out there.
RICK HARRISON: OK.
Let me go make some phone calls.
I'll be right back.
CHRIS: OK.
RICK HARRISON: This
Bira gun is so rare,
I don't think I'll see
another one in my lifetime.
So it would be great to
see this thing in action.
But I have to be 100%
sure when it was made.
So I called to the guy with all
the answers, Mark Hall-Patton.
MARK HALL-PATTON:
This is nice, a Bira.
I've seen pictures
of this gun before.
But I've never
seen one in person.
To be able to see this one
today is really interesting,
and it's in beautiful condition.
This is an amazing piece.
What's your concerns on this?
RICK HARRISON: So this was
definitely made in 1896 or '97.
If it's after 1898, I
can't buy it legally.
MARK HALL-PATTON:
Yeah, they were
only made in 1896 and 1897.
RICK HARRISON: All right, sweet.
MARK HALL-PATTON: Those
are the only two years
that they were produced.
So they're completely
legal to own.
This fire's only
with each crank.
RICK HARRISON: Cool.
MARK HALL-PATTON: Are you
planning on shooting this?
CHRIS: Yeah.
RICK HARRISON:
We're gonna take it
out to the firing range in the
morning and meet up with Alex.
Wanna come?
MARK HALL-PATTON:
Yeah, you mind?
RICK HARRISON: Oh,
yeah, no problem.
MARK HALL-PATTON: Oh, I'd
love to see this thing shot.
RICK HARRISON: I will get some
guys to help you load this.
CHRIS: I would greatly
appreciate that.
RICK HARRISON: All
right, no problem.
MARK HALL-PATTON: It
weighs about 1,100 pounds.
RICK HARRISON: So we're
out in the desert.
I got Alex, my gun
expert coming out to tell
me what this thing is worth.
And we're going to
shoot the Bira gun.
Look at this.
The Bira gun.
The Nepalese, a
man named Gehendra,
was able to smuggle in American
Gardner gun out of England
into Nepal.
And he attempted
to reverse engineer
the American Gardner gun.
And it became the Bira gun.
But he made some
radical changes.
I mean the most notable
change is that pan magazine.
Now this pan magazine holds
120 rounds of this ammunition,
which I brought today.
This is a Martini-Henry
ammunition.
Look at the size of that round.
[gunshot]
It is tremendously unique.
And I have never seen one fire.
RICK HARRISON: Who's first?
MARK HALL-PATTON:
That's why I'm here.
RICK HARRISON: OK,
you're the Guinea pig.
MARK HALL-PATTON: No.
ALEX: I'm steppin' back.
MARK HALL-PATTON: All righty.
[gunfire]
ALEX: Nice, nice.
RICK HARRISON: I've never
loved a gun so much.
MARK HALL-PATTON:
You gotta try it now.
RICK HARRISON: This is sweet.
OK, here we go.
[music playing]
[gunfire]
This is awesome.
[music playing and gunfire]
ALEX: Nice.
Right on target.
RICK HARRISON: I just think
it's absolutely great.
[gunshot]
This gun is awesome.
I mean, really, it's that cool.
It looks really,
really steam punk.
It looks really neat.
It looks really weird.
It's a great show piece.
What's it worth?
ALEX: Well, a few have been sold
over the last couple of years.
The market value for
these is about $27,500.
RICK HARRISON: OK.
So what's your best
price on this thing?
CHRIS: I'm asking $30,000.
I'll give you 18 grand for it.
How about 26?
RICK HARRISON: The
fact of the matter
is I gotta resell this thing.
And $20,000 is
the most I can do.
It's the most I
can pay and still
make sense, plain and simple.
[music playing]
I can do $20,000.
RICK HARRISON: All right, sweet.
I am like a kid
in a candy store.
This is like one
of the coolest guns
I've ever bought in my life.
I just have to test
it a few more times.